>> PREVIOUSLY ON
>> AMERICAN'S NEXT TOP MODEL
>> ACTION AND BEAUTY
CAME TOGETHER
AT A SKY-HIGH PHOTO SHOOT...
>> ARE YOU READY?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> WHERE SOME GIRLS ROSE TO THE
OCCASION...
>> MELROSE, YOU ALWAYS GIVE US
AN AMAZING SHOT.
MAKE THE GIRLS HATE YOU EVEN
MORE.
>> BUT ANCHAL WAS PLAGUED
BY TROUBLE WITH HER ROOMMATES.
>> YOU ACT LIKE YOU'RE A CHILD.
ANCHAL, YOU HAVE NO RESPECT
FOR OTHER PEOPLE'S SPACE.
>> SHE BROUGHT HER INSECURITIES
TO THE JUDGING ROOM ONCE AGAIN.
WE BELIEVE IN ALL OF YOU,
AND THEN YOU JUST THROW
SOMETHING AWAY AND RUN OUT.
IT'S LIKE, WHAT'S THE POINT?
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
>> BYE.
>> SIX GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
DO YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ♪
>> ANCHAL WAS JUST NAIVE
ABOUT THE WORLD.
>> AND I THINK, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
LIKE, SHE HASN'T-- SHE HASN'T
LIVED
WITHOUT HER PARENTS YET.
>> MY SISTER ENDED UP IN THE
BOTTOM TWO,
AND I WAS REALLY NERVOUS,
'CAUSE I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
MY SISTER WAS GONNA GO HOME.
>> AND, MICHELLE,
YOU HAVE TO START SHOWING US
THAT YOU WANT THIS.
>> MY SISTER KNOWS
THAT I'M CONFUSED.
I'VE TOLD HER THAT I'M LIKE,
I HAVE NO IDEA.
'CAUSE I DIDN'T REALLY
WANT TO MODEL,
BUT I WANNA DO IT FOR MY SISTER.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> AAH!
>> "IF YOU THINK THAT I ACT A
FOOL,
WAIT TILL YOU MEET MY GIRL."
>> UH-OH.
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> WE'RE IN TROUBLE.
>> YOU HAVE TO MAKE THE HEART
BEFORE YOU WRITE ON IT.
>> I MISS MY BOYFRIEND.
THAT'S, LIKE, THE HARDEST PART
OF THIS COMPETITION.
I'M SICK OF LIVING IN THIS HOUSE
WITH ALL THESE CHICKS.
>> IT'S BEEN SO LONG
SINCE WE WERE RAVENOUS
IN EACH OTHER'S EMBRACE.
>> I DON'T REALLY HEAR WHAT
THE OTHER GIRLS THINK OF ME,
BUT I DEFINITELY KNOW.
I KNOW THAT THEY THINK I'M
BITCHY AND, YOU KNOW,
I SPEAK MY MIND A LITTLE TOO
MUCH.
>> I WANT IT, BUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO MAKE IT MY DREAM.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO--
DON'T FORCE A DREAM.
>> I KNOW.
>> IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE-- JUST
BECAUSE YOU'RE A MODEL,
IT DOESN'T MEAN IT HAS TO BE
YOUR GREATEST DREAM.
OF THE TWINS, MICHELLE'S LIKE,
"I DON'T REALLY LIKE THIS.
WHATEVER."
FOR THEM, IT'S ALL JUST LIKE AN
EXPERIENCE TO DO.
FOR ME, IT'S A DREAM,
AND I REALLY WANT THIS,
AND I'D HATE FOR ME TO GO HOME
AND HAVE SOMEONE
THAT DOESN'T WANT THIS STAY.
♪ ♪
>> RIGHT WHEN WE GOT TO L.A.
REPERTORY THEATER,
WE HAD AN IDEA WHAT WE'RE DOING,
BUT WE DIDN'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT WAS GONNA GO ON.
>> ARE WE READY
TO ROCK 'N' ROLL?
>> YEAH!
>> ALL RIGHT!
I'M TASHA SMITH, LADIES.
I'M AN ACTRESS,
AND I ALSO TEACH ACTING,
AND I'M A VERY GOOD FRIEND OF
MISS TYRA.
YOU THINK SHE'S CRAZY?
>> I'M ALL RIGHT.
>> WHOA! NO!
>> I KNOW YOU LIKE THIS
BOOTY-BERRY.
>> (shrieking) I AM THE QUEEN!
>> TRUST ME--THIS IS WHERE
SHE GOT THE CRAZY FROM.
AS A MODEL,
YOU KNOW YOUR PHOTOGRAPHERS
ARE GONNA CONSTANTLY
YELL OUT EMOTIONS TO YOU,
AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO DO IT ON CUE.
CARIDEE,
WHY DON'T YOU GET UP HERE?
'CAUSE YOU SEEM LIKE A
LOUDMOUTH.
>> TASHA--
SHE'S LOUD AND ENERGETIC.
SO WE'RE JUST LOOKING FORWARD
TO HAVING AN INTERESTING DAY.
>> ALL RIGHT. THE FIRST
EXERCISE, LADIES,
WE'RE GONNA START OFF WITH
IS CALLED
THE "SILLY-DILLY" EXERCISE.
THIS EXERCISE IS ABOUT BREAKING
DOWN
ALL PHYSICAL BARRIERS
AND BOUNDARIES.
>> I HAVE SPONTANUITY, BITCHES.
>> LET'S DO IT RIGHT NOW.
>> (groans)
>> MORE. WALK CRAZIER. MORE.
WORK IT. (laughs)
YOU CAN GET SILLIER
THAN THAT, GIRL.
COME ON. (laughs)
NOW THAT'S A GIRL
THAT AIN'T AFRAID TO BE UGLY.
YOU'RE DONE.
>> (laughs)
>> LOOK AT THIS BUTT.
COME ON NOW!
>> SILLY. UGLY.
>> (laughing)
>> I'M LOVING YOU, AMANDA.
OFF THE STAGE. COME ON.
>> UGLY FACES.
FACE IS NOT UGLY ENOUGH.
>> (moaning)
>> FACE IS NOT UGLY ENOUGH.
GET OFF THE STAGE.
DISTORT YOUR BODY!
>> (laughs)
>> COME ON. MORE!
>> AMANDA'S A LOT BETTER
AT ACTING, SO I THINK
SHE'S GONNA DO A LITTLE BETTER
THAN ME ON THIS CHALLENGE.
>> YOU'RE NOT TAKING IT
SERIOUS ENOUGH. WORK IT!
>> YOU JUST KIND OF HAD TO
LET GO OF EVERYTHING,
AND SHE HAD US GET INTO
ALL THESE DIFFERENT EMOTIONS.
>> (shrieks)
>> MORE.
THIS NEXT EXERCISE
IS CALLED "DUMP"--
DUMPING OUT
EVERYTHING YOU'RE FEELING.
I WANT YOU TO LET IT OUT
RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU WANNA CRY, CRY.
BUT WHATEVER IT IS
YOU'RE FEELING,
FEEL IT.
>> I FEEL COMPLETELY
OUT OF PLACE,
AND NO MATTER WHAT I DO HERE,
IT NEVER ADDS UP,
AND IT SEEMS LIKE
IT'S SO MUCH EASIER
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> MORE! SCREAM IT
TO THE TOP OF YOUR LUNGS.
>> (sighs)
>> I LIKE YOU GUYS,
AND I JUST--
BUT YOU GUYS PISS ME OFF!
I'M TIRED OF SUFFERING LITTLE.
I'M TIRED OF EVERYTHING.
BUT I WANNA BE HERE.
I WANT TO TAKE GOOD PHOTOS.
I WANNA TRY HARDER.
>> WHATEVER YOU'RE FEELING--
AS OVER-THE-TOP AS POSSIBLE.
>> ALL TYRA SAYS IS THAT,
"OH, YOU DON'T WANT THIS.
YOU DON'T WANT--"
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I... WANT.
THAT'S THE POINT!
I'M NOT VERY GOOD AT EXPRESSING
MY FEELINGS IN FRONT OF PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT MY STRONG POINT,
BUT I FIGURED, YOU KNOW,
JUST GO FOR IT.
THAT'S WHAT PANEL ALWAYS SAYS,
YOU KNOW, I DON'T GO FOR IT,
SO I JUST WENT FOR IT.
I'M TIRED OF NOT KNOWING!
>> THREE...
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT I WANT.
>> ONE.
>> I'M DONE WITH IT.
>> HOW DARE ANYBODY TELL ME
THAT MY PICTURE
IS WORSE THAN YOURS!
I'M WORKING MY ASS OFF
TO BE HERE,
AND YOU SAY
I TAKE A WORSE PICTURE!
AND THEY JUST CHOOSE
A BETTER PICTURE? NO!
I'M WORKING HARDER THAN YOU!
I TAKE THE CRITICISM,
AND I WORK IT MYSELF,
'CAUSE I AM NOT EMPTY!
'CAUSE I WANT TO BE BETTER!
'CAUSE I WANNA... WIN!
>> I THINK--
I THINK MELROSE IS BIPOLAR.
EVERYBODY'S SEEING
HOW WRONG MELROSE IS.
I'M JUST GONNA SAY, SHE'S WRONG.
>> MOST OF YOU GUYS
KNOW HOW I FEEL,
YOU KNOW, ABOUT MY NEW LOOK
AND EVERYTHING,
AND I'M JUST
SICK AND TIRED OF IT.
NOBODY UNDERSTANDS.
I CALL MY BOYFRIEND,
AND HE'S LIKE,
"OH, JUST GET OVER IT.
GET OVER IT."
BUT I DON'T FEEL GREAT.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE A GIRL
AND I DON'T FEEL SEXY,
AND I HATE IT.
WE'RE DOWN TO THE WIRE NOW,
AND I'M NOT HAPPY ALL THE TIME.
AND I FEEL LIKE
PEOPLE ARE MAD AT ME,
BECAUSE THEY EXPECT ME
TO BE ALL FLOWERY AND...
YOU KNOW, ALL ENERGY.
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M JUST REALLY STRESSED.
(sobbing) OH, MY GOD!
>> OKAY, JAEDA.
YOU'RE DONE, HONEY.
>> I'M SICK OF PEOPLE THINKING
THAT MODELS CAN'T FEEL.
I'M SICK OF PEOPLE THINKING
THIS CAREER
IS JUST SOMETHING THAT IS...
THAT IS JUST, LIKE, SO GREAT.
IT'S HARD!
I SEE PEOPLE BREAK DOWN
IN FRONT OF PANEL
AND HAVE THEIR DREAMS SMASHED!
I WANT THIS SO BAD!
I'VE BEEN THROUGH SO MUCH...
I HAVE TRIED KILLING MYSELF.
>> CARIDEE REVEALED SOMETHING
THAT WAS VERY PERSONAL.
THAT WAS JUST, LIKE, A SHOCKER,
YOU KNOW, TO ALL OF US.
>> 'CAUSE I KNOW
WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO WANNA DIE
AND NOT LIVE ANYMORE,
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN MY LIFE,
I FEEL LIKE
I'M DOING SOMETHING RIGHT,
AND I FEEL LIKE I BELONG.
>> CARI,
I'M REALLY PROUD OF YOU.
YOU HEAR ME?
>> YEAH.
>> I KNOW THAT WASN'T EASY.
>> I THINK IT WAS REALLY HARD
FOR CARI UP THERE,
AND I THINK THAT WE WERE
STIRRING UP SO MUCH EMOTION,
AND THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN SO INTENSE
FOR ALL OF US,
THAT WHEN YOU GET UP THERE
AND THOSE EMOTIONS
START ROLLING OUT OF YOUR MOUTH,
THEY JUST KIND OF
TAKE AHOLD OF YOU.
>> THANKS. YOU'RE SO SWEET.
>> NO. BUT DO YOU KNOW HOW RARE
SOMEONE LIKE YOU IS?
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I NEEDED.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT I NEEDED.
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> I JUST STARTED TALKING,
AND, YOU KNOW, BEFORE I KNEW IT,
I WAS SAYING THINGS
AND I WAS CRYING.
AND I DON'T REALLY REMEMBER,
LIKE, THINKING
I WAS GONNA SAY THESE THINGS.
YOU KNOW,
IT WAS JUST A BREAKING POINT.
>> GROUP HUG.
GROUP HUG.
>> OKAY, LET'S GO DO IT.
LET'S GO FINISH
THIS COMPETITION, RIGHT?
OKAY, LADIES.
LET'S WELCOME BACK CARIDEE!
(clapping)
COME ON. GIVE HER A HAND.
IT'S ALL FOR A PURPOSE.
EXPRESSING YOURSELF--
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS ABOUT,
AND YOU ARE GONNA NEED IT
FOR YOUR CHALLENGE.
EVERYBODY IN HERE
IS ABOUT TO SHOOT
THEIR OWN SILENT FILM.
YAY!
>> (laughing)
>> SILENT FILM?
>> YES.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO DO.
NOW, LADIES,
THE PERSON THAT DOES
THE ABSOLUTE BEST
IS GOING TO LAND A ROLE
ON CW's HIT SHOW
"ONE TREE HILL."
>> (cheering)
>> YES. YES. OKAY?
>> ACTUALLY, I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THE SILENT MOVIE.
TASHA'S GONNA BE
YELLING OUT DIRECTIONS TO US,
AND WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO ACT THEM OUT.
>> I WANT YOU
TO RUN TO THE WINDOW.
RUN TO THE WINDOW.
DESPERATELY, DESPERATELY.
OH, MY GOD, A LEMON! YAY!
THERE'S A KNOCK AT THE DOOR.
SAD, BUT STAY SAD.
DRINK THAT PRUNE JUICE
LIKE IT'S THE BEST-TASTING
PRUNE JUICE IN THE WORLD.
>> KEEP CRYING
WHILE YOU'RE TALKING.
YOU'RE SUCH A BAD ACTRESS.
I CAN'T EVEN TAKE IT.
OH, GOD. EVEN IN A SILENT MOVIE,
YOU SUCK.
>> (gasps)
>> BE HOPEFUL. BE HOPEFUL.
WHO COULD IT BE?
THE KOOL-AID IS GOOD.
THE KOOL-AID IS SO GOOD.
RUB YOUR STOMACH.
LOOK REALLY HUNGRY.
OPEN IT UP.
IT'S LIKE A SANDWICH.
IT'S LIKE--IT'S LIKE A RIB.
IT'S A CHEESEBURGER.
WOW.
IT'S SOMEBODY WITH A TELEGRAM.
YOU'RE EXCITED.
OH, NO, BUT IT'S BAD NEWS.
I'M A BROKE,
DOWN-AND-OUT MODEL
THAT LOOKS LIKE A BOY NOW
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE MY HAIR.
>> IT WAS REALLY HARD,
'CAUSE SHE MADE ME EAT A LEMON,
AND I WAS, LIKE, THE ONLY ONE
WHO ATE THE WHOLE THING
AND SWALLOWED IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I JUST REALLY
NEEDED TO DO MY BEST,
BECAUSE I DON'T GET
THIS KIND OF OPPORTUNITY
VERY OFTEN.
>> YOU CAN'T HIDE YOUR FACE.
I SAID, BITE THE LEMON.
CRY UNCONTROLLABLY.
EVEN MORE.
>> (wailing)
I'M TRYING
TO KEEP A STRAIGHT FACE
AND GO THROUGH THESE EMOTIONS
WHILE TASHA'S LITERALLY
YELLING AT US.
>> (sobbing)
>> KEEP TALKING
TO THE PERSON ON THE PHONE.
>> ME AND PRUNE JUICE
DON'T MIX VERY WELL,
SO, UM, I DRANK A BIG OLD GULP
AND...
(belches)
>> YOU'RE NOT STAYING
IN CHARACTER.
>> I AM 135% SURE THAT
I'M NOT GONNA WIN THE CHALLENGE.
>> IS THERE A BAG ANYWHERE?
>> ACTUALLY, I'M 200% SURE
I'M NOT GONNA WIN THE CHALLENGE.
>> I BETTER SEE SOME THROW-UP,
'CAUSE I-I-I JUST
DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
LADIES,
THANK YOU FOR A WONDERFUL DAY,
AND YOU'RE GONNA KNOW
WHO THE WINNER IS VERY SOON.
CONGRATULATIONS AND GOOD LUCK
TO ALL OF YOU GUYS.
>> TELL ME ABOUT YOUR DAY.
I WANNA HEAR ABOUT
WHY IT WAS SO BAD.
>> BECAUSE I LET OUT MY BIGGEST
SECRET,
AND I DIDN'T MEAN TO.
>> HOW'D THAT HAPPEN?
>> BECAUSE THEY HAD US, LIKE,
GO THROUGH OUR EMOTIONS, AND I
WAS, LIKE, UP THERE CRYING,
AND THEN, LIKE, I GO, "FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN MY LIFE,
I FEEL LIKE I'M DOING SOMETHING
RIGHT.
I FEEL LIKE I'M ACTUALLY HERE
FOR A REASON."
>> AW, SWEETIE.
THAT MUST HAVE BEEN SO HARD.
>> IT WAS A NICE RELEASE.
THERE'S NOTHING HOLDING ME BACK
RIGHT NOW,
AND I FEEL SO LIBERATED AND
FREE,
LIKE, I'M JUST GOING FOR IT,
BECAUSE NOTHING IS GOING TO STOP
ME.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> WE HAVE DVD MAIL.
>> "MY GOOD FRIEND TASHA
CHOSE A WINNER.
SO POP IN THIS DISC
AND SEE WHO MADE A SCENE.
BELIEVE ME,
THE WINNER WON'T BE
THE ONLY ONE SURPRISED."
OH, TYRA.
(OLD-TIMEY PIANO MUSIC PLAYING)
>> DAISY.
>> (LAUGHING)
>> AAH!
>> (LAUGHS)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> (LAUGHING)
>> DAMN, GIRL.
YOU'RE AWESOME.
>> (LAUGHS) FROM COWBOY CAL?
>> (LAUGHING)
>> "HORSES RULE."
>> "P.S. HORSES RULE"!
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> (SCREAMS)
>> "WHAT'S THE MATTER, BOO?"
>> "MY BOYFRIEND LEFT ME
FOR A HORSE!"
>> AAH! YAY.
>> WHAT?
>> OH, MY GOD.
WE'RE GOING SOMEWHERE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
>> WHERE ARE WE GOING?
>> "PACK YOUR BAGS, GIRLS"!
AAH!
>> (SCREAMING)
>> 'CAUSE YOU'RE ALL GOING TO...
SPAIN!
>> (SCREAMING)
(SPANISH MUSIC PLAYING)
>> I'M SO EXCITED TO GO TO SPAIN
BECAUSE I FEEL MORE LIKE
I'M PART OF THIS COMPETITION
AND LIKE I HAVE A CHANCE.
>> I'M WAITING FOR
MY ALARM CLOCK TO GO OFF.
I'M WINNING THIS GREAT PRIZE.
I'M FULFILLING MY DREAM
OF WANTING TO BE AN ACTRESS
ALSO.
OH, MY GOSH.
I'M GOING TO SPAIN.
>> (SCREAMS)
>> WHOO! WHOO!
>> TODAY I'M DOING
MY CHALLENGE WIN.
I AM A GUEST STAR
ON "ONE TREE HILL."
TODAY I'M PLAYING
A GIRL NAMED TIA.
I'M A MODEL THAT COMES IN TOWN
AND STIRS THINGS UP
A LITTLE BIT.
>> OKAY.
LET'S GET IT QUIET, PLEASE.
HERE'S THE REHEARSAL.
>> ACTION.
>> CAN YOU COME HERE
AND HELP ME PUT ON MY SHOE?
I DON'T WANT TO CHIP A NAIL.
>> CARIDEE'S PERFORMING
PRETTY WELL.
IT'S TOUGH TO COME
INTO AN ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS,
WHERE, YOU KNOW--
THIS IS A SHOW THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR THREE YEARS.
>> FOR HER FIRST TIME
AS A REAL,
HONEST-TO-GOODNESS ACTRESS,
SHE'S DOING GREAT.
THAT'S A WRAP ON CARIDEE.
>> YAY!
>> AFTER ALL IS SAID AND DONE,
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY,
SO I'M GOING HOME
AND TAKING A LONG BUBBLE BATH.
♪ ♪
(HORN HONKS)
>> I DIDN'T REALLY KNOW
IF WE'D MAKE IT TO THE TOP SIX.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
IF WE'D MAKE IT TO TOP 13.
YOU JUST NEVER KNOW,
AND YOU GOTTA GO
WITH WHAT HAPPENS,
AND WHO KNOWS?
YOU MIGHT SEE THE TWINS
IN THE FINAL TWO.
♪ ♪
>> IT FEELS MUY BUENO
TO BE IN SPAIN!
YAY!
>> WE FIRST GET OFF THE PLANE,
AND WE JUST SEE
ALL THIS SPANISH,
AND WE CAN'T READ ANYTHING
AROUND US.
>> WHOO!
>> BEING PART OF THE TOP SIX
IS REALLY EXCITING.
IT'S KIND OF CRAZY.
IT'S, LIKE, REALLY GETTING
NARROWED DOWN.
AND IT KIND OF FEELS
JUST LIKE BEFORE,
BUT WITH LESS PEOPLE.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "BENVINGUTS A CATALUNYA.
WELCOME TO BARCELONA."
(LAUGHS)
"HOPE YOU HAD A RELAXING FLIGHT
BECAUSE I'VE GOT SOME BAD NEWS
TO BREAK TO YOU."
>> OOH.
>> THIS COMPETITION IS GETTING
TOO EASY,
SO I'VE ADDED SOME LOCAL MODELS
INTO THE MIX TO SEE
WHO TRULY HAS WHAT IT TAKES."
>> UH-OH.
>> "STAY ON YOUR TOES,
BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW
WHERE THEY'LL SHOW UP.
HUGS AND KISSES, TYRA."
>> I'M LIKE, OH, GOD.
LIKE, SPANISH WOMEN
ARE SO BEAUTIFUL.
I DON'T WANT TO COMPETE WITH
THEM.
♪ ♪
>> ONCE WE GET INTO THE CITY,
WE SEE ALL THE GORGEOUS
ARCHITECTURE'S AMAZING.
THE BUILDINGS ARE GORGEOUS.
THE SPANISH PEOPLE MUST GO TO
AMERICA
AND BE LIKE, "WHAT THE HELL?"
>> OH, THERE'S A GUY
STANDING THERE WITH FLOWERS.
OOH, HE'S KIND OF CUTE.
>> HEY.
>> HI.
>> I'M CHRIS.
I'M A MALE MODEL FROM BARCELONA.
>> WHEN WE SAW THE CUTE MODEL
WITH THE "TOP MODEL'S"
TOUR SIGN,
WE WERE REALLY RELIEVED
THAT IT'S A MALE MODEL
AND THAT IT'S PROBABLY
GONNA BE FUN.
>> I GOT SOME ROSES FOR YOU.
>> AW!
>> IT REPRESENTS THE PASSION OF
THE SPAIN.
>> WOW.
>> SINCE WE'VE ALL BEEN
SO VERY MUCH MALE-DEPRIVED,
IT WAS FUN
TO HAVE JUST A DIFFERENT SEX
IN THE GROUP BECAUSE...
(LAUGHS) HANGING AROUND
WITH A BUNCH OF FEMALES--
FOR ME, IT'S REALLY IRRITATING,
'CAUSE I'M A GIRLY GIRL,
BUT REALLY
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT,
I'M JUST, LIKE, MENTALLY LIKE A
MAN.
>> WE'RE PICKING UP OUR MODELS
ALONG THE WAY!
HERE HE COMES.
>> WHAT DOES HE HAVE?
>> HI.
>> THIS IS FOR YOU.
>> THE BUS WAS ACTUALLY
REALLY COMFORTABLE.
THE MALE MODELS
WERE VERY GOOD-LOOKING.
>> HI, LUCAS.
>> WE HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> THEY DIDN'T REALLY
SPEAK A LOT OF ENGLISH.
I THINK THE FIRST ONE WE PICKED
UP WAS THE ONE
WHO SPOKE THE MOST ENGLISH.
>> HAVE YOU EVER TRIED
ANY SPANISH FOOD AT ALL?
>> UM...
>> UNH-UNH.
>> BEANS AND RICE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THAT'S SO FUNNY.
♪ ♪
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WE ORDERED UP PURE,
TRADITIONAL CATALAN DINNER.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> "TOMORROW YOU SHOOT A
COMMERCIAL
IN THE NATIVE TONGUE."
>> OH!
>> "SO HERE'S YOUR SCRIPT.
MEMORIZE IT.
PICK A MALE MODEL RIGHT NOW
AND GET READY
FOR AN ON-SCREEN-KISS DEBUT
WITH YOUR NEW BOO.
HUGS AND KISSES, TYRA."
>> OH, GOD!
>> OH, NO. YOU'RE JOKING, RIGHT?
'CAUSE WE ARE ALL
HAVING THE HARDEST TIME
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THESE BOYS,
AND NOW WE HAVE TO SPEAK
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
>> (TRILLS)
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> WE HAVE TO PRACTICE.
>> NO, I-I...
IN THIS MOMENT, I ONLY EATING.
NO PRACTICE, OKAY?
>> WELL, WHAT IF WE DON'T
GET TO PRACTICE ANYMORE?
>> NO SÉ. I DON'T KNOW.
>> (SPEAKS CATALAN) GOOD.
>> SO DO YOU WANT ME
TO BE LIKE THAT?
>> YOU WHAT?
>> DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
>> NO.
>> DO YOU THINK,
"OH, MAKE OUT." THAT OKAY?
>> GOOD.
>> JAEDA'S PARTNER NACHO
TELLS JAEDA THAT HE DOESN'T
EVEN LIKE BLACK GIRLS.
SHE'S LIKE, "ARE YOU SERIOUS?"
>> NO ONE SHOULD BE TREATED LIKE
THAT.
I WOULD HATE IF I HAD THAT GUY.
AND I'D MAKE OUT WITH,
LIKE, AMANDA
BEFORE I'D MAKE OUT WITH HIM.
>> HE DOESN'T WANT TO HELP ME.
>> DO YOU LIKE THE RABBIT?
>> I'M WORRIED ABOUT TOMORROW'S
SHOOT,
BECAUSE I HAVE TO MAKE OUT WITH
THIS GUY
WHO'S AN IDIOT AND A JERK,
AND HE SAYS HE DOESN'T LIKE
BLACK GIRLS.
>> BYE, GIRLS.
>> BYE.
>> I WAS, LIKE,
SO EXCITED TO GO TO SPAIN,
AND NOW, YOU KNOW,
MY FIRST NIGHT, IT'S JUST LIKE,
OKAY, THAT'S KIND OF RUINED.
>> (GASPS)
>> WHOO!
>> COOL!
>> THIS IS BEAUTIFUL.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WE FIGURED WE'D BE STAYING IN
A HOTEL,
MAYBE SOMETHING, YOU KNOW,
AMERICANIZED.
BUT NO, IT'S A REALLY AUTHENTIC,
VERY NICE SPANISH APARTMENT.
IT'S ACTUALLY REALLY GORGEOUS.
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> "WELCOME TO YOUR NEW LAIR,
WHERE YOU'LL SOON
REST YOUR HEAD.
BY THE WAY,
THE CHALLENGE WINNER
HAS THE FIRST CHOICE
OF HER BED."
>> OOH.
>> "LOVE, TYRA"!
THAT'S ME, EH?
>> CLEARLY,
SHE CHOSE THE BIG ROOM
WITH THE BIG BED
AND ALL THE CLOSET SPACE.
>> I GET TO SPREAD OUT SO FAR!
♪ ♪
>> (SPEAKS CATALAN)
I STAYED UP TWO EXTRA HOURS
LAST NIGHT STUDYING
BECAUSE I WANTED
TO KNOW THESE LINES.
AND I HAD THEM DOWN.
>> (SPEAKS CATALAN)
CATALAN IS A NATIVE LANGUAGE.
LIKE, IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF SPANISH MIXED
WITH A BUNCH OF OTHER DIALECTS
FROM AROUND THE WORLD.
I CAN'T ROLL MY TONGUE
NATURALLY.
I SOUND LIKE A DEAD CAR.
(IMITATES TRILLING)
>> (SPEAKS CATALAN)
>> YOU GOTTA MEMORIZE THAT.
(GROWLS)
>> I DON'T KISS A LOT OF GUYS.
IN FACT, I HAVEN'T KISSED A GUY
SINCE I WAS, LIKE, 10.
IT WAS MY NEIGHBOR,
BEHIND A SHED.
HOPEFULLY, I DON'T SUCK,
AND HOPEFULLY,
IT ISN'T TOO AWKWARD.
>> I DON'T THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO KISS THE GUYS.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> YES, WE ARE. WE'RE HAVING
A SERIOUS MAKE-OUT SESH.
>> I'M LOYAL TO MY BOYFRIEND--
LIKE, REALLY LOYAL.
KISSING THIS RANDOM GUY
WHO'S SO RUDE--
THAT REALLY SUCKS.
>> WELL, CHEERS.
YOU'LL BE FINE.
(MUGS CLINK)
(HORN HONKS)
♪ ♪
>> HEY.
>> OH, MY GOSH!
>> YES, THEY ARE!
>> HI, EVERYBODY.
>> HI.
>> BIENVENIDOS A ESPAÑA!
>> GRACIAS.
>> WHOO!
>> BARCELONA IS
THE FASHION CAPITAL OF SPAIN,
AND I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU ALL KNOW CUSTO BARCELONA.
HAVE YOU HEARD OF THAT DESIGNER?
AND WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
THE FAMOUS BALENCIAGA BAGS
THAT ALL THE CELEBRITIES WEAR.
AND ALSO ESTHER CAÑADAS
IS A REALLY FAMOUS MODEL.
SHE HAS BLOND HAIR,
AND SHE HAS LIPS
BIGGER THAN MINE,
CARIDEE'S AND MELROSE'S
AND EUGENA'S PUT TOGETHER.
>> (LAUGHING)
>> WELL, THEY'RE FROM SPAIN.
THEY'RE FROM HERE.
ARE Y'ALL READY TO GET YOUR DAY
STARTED?
>> YEAH!
>> YEAH?
AND DID EVERYBODY CHOOSE A MAN?
YOU DON'T LIKE YOURS?
>> HE SAID HE DIDN'T LIKE...
>> BLACK GIRLS. (LAUGHS)
>> HE SAID HE DIDN'T LIKE
BLACK GIRLS?
>> SO I WAS LIKE,
OH, THIS IS GOOD.
>> WELL, YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO GIVE HIM A KISS TO MAKE HIM
LOVE SOME BLACK GIRLS,
BECAUSE WHAT DO THEY SAY?
ONCE THEY GO BLACK...
>> THEY DON'T GO BACK.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> (LAUGHING)
>> ALL RIGHT, SO, JAY MANUEL,
GET OUT HERE!
>> WHOO!
>> HI, PRECIOUS.
OH, NO. WE HAVE TO DO TWO.
>> OH. MWAH, MWAH.
>> HOLA. BESOS.
OKAY, BESOS, AMIGAS.
ADIOS.
WHOO! LOOK AT THAT! THAT'S A
GREAT EXIT--
>> I KNOW, WITH THE BIRDS.
>> WITH THE BIRDS.
WHOO!
>> SEE YOU, TYRA.
SO ARE YOU GUYS EXCITED?
>> YEAH.
>> THE COMMERCIAL TODAY
IS FOR SECRET DEODORANT.
SO IT'S ALL ABOUT DISPLAYING
STRENGTH AND CONFIDENCE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE PRESSURE'S
ON,
AND TODAY THE PRESSURE IS ON.
WE'RE GOING TO CELEBRATE
THE STRENGTH OF THE WOMEN HERE
IN BARCELONA,
AND SPEAK IN THEIR LANGUAGE,
WHICH IS CATALAN.
ALL RIGHTY?
COME ON, LET'S GO.
(SPANISH MUSIC PLAYING)
>> I AM FEELING OVERWHELMED.
THIS IS THE HARDEST THING I'VE
EVER DONE IN MY LIFE,
TRYING TO MEMORIZE
THIS LANGUAGE THAT YOU'VE NEVER
HEARD OF BEFORE.
>> I WAS PRETTY SURE EVERYBODY
WAS GONNA MAKE A BIG DEAL OUT OF
MY KISS SCENE,
WHICH I HAD NO PROBLEM WITH.
I WAS LIKE, WHATEVER. I GOTTA
KISS HIM.
LET'S JUST DO IT.
I WAS MORE WORRIED ABOUT
THE LANGUAGE THAN THE KISS.
>> NOW I WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU
GUYS
TO YOUR COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR.
DENIS, COME UP HERE.
>> HOLA.
>> YOU'RE WALKING THROUGH
ALL THESE SEXY MEN,
KIND OF TELLING
YOUR LITTLE SECRETS.
BUT YOU'VE GOT A BIG SECRET
AT THE END.
MAKE ME BELIEVE THIS, MICHELLE.
>> ACCIÓN!
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> WE GOT THESE CUE CARDS
TO READ OFF OF, BUT...
LIKE, YOU GO IN THERE THINKING
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GONNA SAY.
YOU PARTLY MEMORIZE THE LINES,
AND YOU'RE LIKE, OKAY,
IF I SEE HOW--HOW IT'S WRITTEN,
I'LL BE ABLE TO SAY IT.
BUT NO, IT'S COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
>> (SPEAKS CATALAN)
>> SECRET... (SPEAKS CATALAN)
>> CUT!
>> WHOO!
>> THE PART THAT I THOUGHT
WAS GONNA BE HORRENDOUS, WHICH
WAS THE KISS,
WAS THE BEST PART ABOUT THE
WHOLE THING.
YOU WERE KIND OF GIVING
THE CAMERA A COLD SHOULDER.
>> SO IT DOESN'T MATTER IF I GET
WORDS WRONG?
>> YOU CAN BREAK THE DIALOGUE,
IF IT'S TOO LONG.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
MY STRATEGY WAS,
ACT LIKE I KNEW WHAT I WAS
TALKING ABOUT,
AND THAT WAS IT.
AND THEN WE GOT TO THE KISS
PART,
AND IT WAS, LIKE, THE WORST KISS
I'VE EVER HAD IN MY LIFE.
IT WAS LIKE TRYING TO KISS
MY CLOSED FIST,
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> BASED OFF SOME OF YOUR PHOTO
SHOOTS,
THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN FLAT,
BUT YOU WERE REALLY PERSONABLE,
AND THAT'S A GOOD THING.
>> ROLL CÁMARA!
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> (LAUGHS)
I'M NOT REALLY GOOD AT READING
CUE CARDS,
EVEN IF THEY'RE IN ENGLISH.
SO ONCE I FORGOT SOMETHING,
AND I HAD TO READ THE CUE CARD,
IT JUST WENT AWFUL.
SECRET... (SPEAKS CATALAN)
>> AMANDA AND MICHELLE WERE
BORING,
BUT IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
NOT PASSIONATE AND NOT SEXY.
>> BAD!
>> THIS GUY IS A JERK,
AND I DON'T WANT TO TALK TO HIM,
I DON'T WANT TO LOOK AT HIM,
AND I CERTAINLY DON'T EVER WANT
TO KISS HIM.
I FEEL SO SICK RIGHT NOW.
(SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> I CANNOT DO THIS.
OH, MY GOD.
>> ACTIONS SPEAK LOUDER THAN
WORDS.
SO IF YOU LOOK DEFEATED,
IT READS AS DEFEAT.
>> OKAY... (SPEAKS CATALAN)
(SIGHS)
>> JAEDA, SHOULD I TELL YOU
SOMETHING?
FIRST OF ALL, YOU CAN'T CRY
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE TIME
TO FIX YOUR MAKEUP.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
>> I JUST--I CAN'T DO THIS.
I'M CRYING BECAUSE I'M
FRUSTRATED.
I'M FRUSTRATED THAT I HAVE TO
KISS THIS GUY,
AND I'M FRUSTRATED
THAT I SUCK REALLY BAD AT THIS.
I JUST HOPE I DON'T EVER
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT AGAIN.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
I'M THINKING IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
FOR ME TO BE IN CHARACTER
AND REALLY GET
THE CHARACTER DOWN
THAN TO GET THESE LINES 100%.
(SPEAKS CATALAN)
SECRET... (SPEAKS CATALAN)
>> FOR THE DAY, THAT WAS
PROBABLY
ONE OF THE BEST READS.
>> IT WAS?
>> TRUST ME.
>> (EXHALES DEEPLY)
>> OKAY. GOOD LUCK.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU REMEMBER STEPS?
>> YEP. YEP. I--YEAH, PRETTY
MUCH.
YEAH, IF I SCREW UP,
YOU CAN YELL AT ME.
>> ACTION!
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN HALTINGLY)
(BLEEP)
>> CARIDEE'S CATALAN SOUNDED
LIKE SWEDISH/CANTONESE.
IT WAS SO PAINFUL TO WATCH.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> IT WAS AWFUL.
>> I COULDN'T EVEN TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW THE FIRST LINE.
(SPEAKS CATALAN HALTINGLY)
UN SECRET.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
I SPEAK ENGLISH.
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET WITH
THE JUDGES.
ONLY FIVE WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE
JUDGES ARE GONNA SAY
ABOUT MY COMMERCIAL.
AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I
REALLY, LIKE, BOMBED.
THEY'RE GONNA BE ROUGH.
I KNOW IT.
♪ ♪
>> HOLA, CHICAS BONITAS.
>> HOLA.
>> BIENVENIDOS A LA...
(SPEAKING CATALAN)
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS?
>> NO, TYRA.
>> "WELCOME TO THE JUDGING
ROOM."
(GROWLS)
>> (LAUGHS)
>> THE TOP SIX THAT MADE IT
ACROSS THE WATER.
THAT'S A REALLY, REALLY BIG
FEAT.
YOU ALL KNOW OUR PRIZES, RIGHT?
A CONTRACT WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD--
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT...
A COVER AND 6-PAGE SPREAD
IN "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
BUT TODAY THEY'RE ESPAÑA.
OUR PRIMERO JUDGE ES
NIGEL BARKER.
>> HEY, LADIES.
GOOD TO SEE YA.
>> GIVE 'EM SOME SPANISH, NIGEL.
>> HOLA.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THE ENGLISH ARE NOT
GOOD WITH SPANISH.
>> (BRITISH ACCENT) HOLA.
HOLA, NIGEL.
(NORMAL VOICE)
THE NEXT IS THE SEXY, LOVELY
AND TOUSLED-HAIRED
RUNWAY DIVA COACH EXTRAORDINAIRE
MISS J. ALEXANDER.
>> ¿CÓMO 'TA?
>> AND LEGENDARY
FASHION ICON TWIGGY.
>> HOLA!
ISN'T IT GREAT TO BE IN
BARCELONA?
(LAUGHTER)
>> AND YOUR COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR
THIS WEEK, DENIS ROVIRA.
>> HI. ¿CÓMO ESTÁIS?
>> HOLA.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT IS TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE WILL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
MICHELLE.
MICHELLE, SO THIS WEEK,
YOU LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
PHYSICALITY AND EVERYTHING,
AND THAT ALL CULMINATED
INTO A COMMERCIAL WHICH
YOU HAD TO SPEAK IN CATALAN.
YOU HAD TO SELL SECRET
DEODORANT,
AND THERE WAS A NICE LITTLE
SURPRISE
AT THE END OF THE COMMERCIAL
THAT I'LL SAVE FOR THE JUDGES.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT THE FINISHED PRODUCT.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> MICHELLE,
SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST TAKE.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> SECRET... (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> SAY IT LOOKING AT
THE CAMERA, PLEASE.
>> SECRET... (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> AGAIN.
>> (CHUCKLES) WELL, THE KISS
WAS GOOD UNTIL YOU CAME UP.
>> MM-HMM.
>> HAVE YOU EVER KISSED A BOY
BEFORE?
>> WHEN I WAS, LIKE, 10.
>> (LAUGHS)
>> THAT DOESN'T COUNT.
I WAS REALLY ENJOYING
WATCHING YOU,
BUT I WAS NOT ENJOYING
LISTENING TO YOU.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT YOU DIDN'T RELATE
TO ANY OF THE BOYS YOU WERE
TALKING TO.
EVEN IF YOU ARE READING,
YOU'VE GOTTA JUST
TAKE IT IN FOR A SECOND,
THEN LOOK TO THE MODEL
AND HAVE A CHAT WITH HIM.
YOU JUST DIDN'T DO THAT.
>> YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THE WORDS IN ENGLISH,
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE JUST SAYING,
"SECRET... (SPEAKING CATALAN)"
WHAT THE HECK IS THAT?
BUT IF YOU'RE SAYING,
"SECRET'S STRONG ENOUGH FOR A
WOMAN,"
YOU'RE GONNA GO...
(SPEAKING CATALAN)
WELL, THANK YOU, MICHELLE.
EUGENA.
ALL RIGHT, EUGENA,
SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST TAKE.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> SECRET... (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> ALL RIGHT, EUGENA, I GOTTA
SAY THAT SO FAR YOU'RE THE BEST.
>> YES.
>> DID YOU KIND OF, LIKE,
AD LIB SOME WORDS UP IN HERE?
>> (LAUGHS) YEAH, I DID. I AD
LIBBED A LOT OF 'EM.
>> YOU DID A VERY GOOD JOB
BECAUSE I KIND OF TRIED
TO FOLLOW AND I THOUGHT,
THAT DON'T SOUND RIGHT,
BUT IT SOUNDS RIGHT.
>> I'M IMPRESSED WITH YOU.
ALL RIGHT, EUGENA, THANK YOU.
CARIDEE.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
(SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> SE--
OH, SORRY.
>> YEAH.
>> THE WEIRDEST CATALAN I EVER
HEARD,
BUT SHE LOOKED VERY BEAUTIFUL.
>> THE CATALAN?
THAT WAS THE LEAST OF YOUR
PROBLEMS.
>> YEAH.
>> SWEETHEART, YOU ALMOST LOOKED
DRUNK IN THAT,
AND YOU LOOKED A LITTLE CRAZY TO
ME.
IT WAS LIKE A TRAIN WRECK.
>> YOU WERE SPEAKING
"SPAPANESE."
>> (CHUCKLES)
>> IT WAS SUCH A MIXTURE AND YOU
WERE LOST IN TRANSLATION.
>> YOU KNOW,IT'S VERY
DISAPPOINTING, CARIDEE, BECAUSE
THE GIRL
THAT WON THE CHALLENGE
AND THE GIRL THAT'S BEEN
DOING SO WELL
IN THIS COMPETITION IS NOT HERE.
IT LOOKS VERY AMATEUR.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
YOU CAME OVERSEAS,
AND YOU'RE ONE OF THE TOP SIX.
YOU WERE THE CHALLENGE WINNER,
BUT...
TO ME, THAT KINDA CANCELED IT
OUT.
>> IT--IT WAS UNFORGIVABLE.
>> WELL, YES, BUT ALSO MEMORABLE
BECAUSE IT WAS THAT BAD.
>> YEAH.
>> ALL RIGHT, CARIDEE.
>> (MOUTHS WORDS)
>> JAEDA.
JAEDA, YOU LOOK NERVOUS.
>> I...
BLEW THIS, MAN.
>> THANKS FOR THE WARNING.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST TAKE.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> ...MAN.
(SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> HMM?
>> I THINK YOU WERE RIGHT TO
WARN US.
>> YES.
>> (LAUGHS) IT WAS LIKE
WATCHING A CAR CRASH.
OH, GOD.
>> THAT WAS A BIG OLD OPEN SORE.
>> THAT WAS APPALLING.
I MEAN, IT'S...
>> YOU OBVIOUSLY CANNOT ACT.
YOU JUST FELL FLAT ON YOUR FACE,
REALLY.
>> I CRIED. I WAS SO MAD.
I SAT THERE AND CRIED
ON--ON SET.
I JUST--I WAS SO ANGRY.
>> WHO WERE YOU ANGRY WITH?
>> (CRYING) MYSELF.
I COULDN'T DO IT, AND I WAS SO
ANGRY.
I COULD NOT GET IT TOGETHER.
>> WELL, JAEDA,
IF IT WASN'T THE LANGUAGE,
IT HAS TO BE SOMETHING DEEPER
THAN LANGUAGE.
>> I WAS NERVOUS AND I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THE END--
OKAY, THIS GUY DOESN'T LIKE ME.
>> WHEN I SPOKE TO YOU GUYS,
YOU TOLD ME THAT THIS WAS THE
GUY THAT SAID
THAT HE DIDN'T WANNA KISS A
BLACK GIRL?
>> HE DOESN'T LIKE BLACK GIRLS.
>> OH!
>> OH, I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
>> THAT GUY SAID THAT?
>> HE TOLD ME THAT, TO ME,
THE NIGHT BEFORE,THEN I FEEL
LIKE
HE'S CRAWLING IN HIS SKIN JUST
TO KISS ME.
>> BOTTOM LINE IS, YOU'VE GOTTA
TAKE CONTROL.
>> EXACTLY.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT HIM.
HE'S JUST AN EXTRA.
>> THAT SHOULD NOT HAVE
STOPPED HER FROM DOING THE JOB
THAT SHE WAS SENT THERE TO DO.
>> I-I CAN SYMPATHIZE WITH YOU
FOR, YOU KNOW, A GUY SAYING THAT
HE DOESN'T LIKE YOU,
BUT IT PRETTY MUCH WAS DREADFUL.
BUT THE LITTLE TOUCH WAS EVERY
NOW AND THEN THE LIGHT CAUGHT
YOUR FACE
AND YOU LOOKED ABSOLUTELY
RADIANT.
UP NEXT IS MELROSE.
SO, MELROSE,
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> (LAUGHS)
(SPEAKING CATALAN)
SECRET... (SPEAKING CATALAN)
>> IT'S NOT PERFECT CATALAN,
BUT I-I FELT LIKE
I COULD DIRECT YOU.
>> I DON'T SPEAK SPANISH.
I DON'T SPEAK CATALAN.
I UNDERSTOOD EVERYTHING YOU WERE
SAYING.
I LOVED THE WAY YOU...
WITH EVERYONE,
EVEN THE PEOPLE WALKING THROUGH,
YOU LINKED WITH, YOU LAUGHED,
YOU FILLED THE SPACE.
IT WAS BRILLIANT.
>> I STAYED UP FOR AN EXTRA TWO
HOURS BEFORE I WENT TO BED--
EVEN THOUGH WE ONLY GOT, LIKE,
FOUR HOURS OF SLEEP--
TO TRY AND MEMORIZE IT.
>> ONE OF MY FAVORITE PARTS
OF IT WAS IN THE END
WHEN YOU WERE KINDA IN HIS FACE,
AND THEN UP AND THEN, LIKE,
DOWN, AND THEN UP
AND THEN DOWN AND THEN UP.
THAT'S WHAT GIRLS DO WHEN
THEY'RE, LIKE, IN LOVE.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, AMANDA.
SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST TAKE.
>> (SPEAKING CATALAN)
(LAUGHTER)
>> OH!
>> SECRET... (SPEAKING CATALAN)
(LAUGHTER)
>> THAT'S WHAT-- THAT'S WHAT IT
LOOKED LIKE.
IT CAME OFF LIKE THAT...
>> (GROANS)
>> WHICH IS THE PROBLEM.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO FOR IT. YOU'VE
GOTTA COMMIT.
THE BEGINNING OF THE COMMERCIAL,
I THOUGHT YOU LOOKED BEAUTIFUL,
IT WAS GRACEFUL,
AND THE CAMERA LIKES YOU.
>> I-I AGREE.
THE CAMERA LOVES YOU,
WHICH IS A PLUS,
THEN YOU STARTED TRIPPING WITH
THE WORDS
AND YOU LOST IT.
>> YEAH.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, AMANDA.
ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND AFTER THAT I WILL
CALL YOU BACK
AND ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
IS GONNA HAVE TO GO BACK
TO THE U.S. OF A.
>> MELROSE, THAT KIND OF PISSED
ME OFF.
>> IT'S LIKE YOU GO OUT OF YOUR
WAY TRYING
TO MAKE EVERYBODY ELSE LOOK BAD.
>> NO, I DON'T.
>> ALL I SAID IS I STAYED UP AN
EXTRA TWO HOURS.
>> YOU KNOW WHY YOU SAID IT,
THOUGH. YOU WERE--
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW WHY.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
TO DECIDE
WHO IS GOING BACK TO THE STATES.
EUGENA.
>> EUGENA, TODAY, WAS
ONE OF THE PLEASANT SURPRISES.
SHE CAME ALIVE FOR ME.
>> I THOUGHT EUGENA DECIDED SHE
WOULD JUST COME FORWARD
AND REALLY GIVE
A GREAT PERFORMANCE.
>> I THINK SHE HAS MORE
POTENTIAL
THAN SHE SHOWED ON CAMERA.
>> THE ONE THING I LOVE
ABOUT EUGENA RIGHT NOW IS THAT
SHE'S SHOWING VULNERABILITY.
SHE HAD THIS HARD EXTERIOR
WHERE IT'S, LIKE, HER AGAINST
THE WORLD,
AND NOW SHE SEES WE'RE ON HER
SIDE.
MELROSE.
>> THE EXTRA COUPLE OF HOURS
OF STUDYING
REALLY, REALLY HELPED.
>> I THINK IT MIGHT BE
ONE OF THE BEST COMMERCIALS
EVER ON "TOP MODEL,"
PERFORMANCE-WISE.
>> YEAH, AND IT WAS. IT WAS A
GREAT PERFORMANCE.
SHE'S A GREAT ACTRESS.
SHE SOLD ME ON THAT.
SHE STILL LOOKED A LITTLE OLD TO
ME.
>> JAEDA.
>> I THOUGHT JAEDA KNEW SHE WAS
GONNA BE BAD.
SHE HAD ALREADY PREPARED US FOR
IT.
THANK GOD SHE DID,BECAUSE THE
SHOCK-ITRIES
ON OUR FACES WAS NOT...
(SINGSONG VOICE)
CUTE.
>> OKAY, SO SHE CAN'T ACT.
CAN SHE MODEL?
WITH A BONE STRUCTURE LIKE THAT,
WITH THE RIGHT PHOTOGRAPHERS,
IT'S GONNA WORK.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GETTING WITH
HER, I'M NOT SURE.
MICHELLE.
>> I ACTUALLY THOUGHT MICHELLE
WAS PRETTY AWFUL.
I WANTED TO CLOSE MY EYES,
AND I DON'T THINK SHE LOOKED
VERY GOOD ON CAMERA.
>> ME, I'M FINDING THAT AMANDA
IS SHINING NOW
MORE THAN HER SISTER.
>> I HAVE TO DISAGREE WITH ALL
OF YOU.
I THOUGHT MICHELLE LOOKED
FABULOUS IN THE COMMERCIAL,
BUT I THOUGHT HER PERFORMANCE
WAS...
(PURRS)
AMANDA.
>> AMANDA--I THINK SHE HAS
GOOD POTENTIAL VISUALLY.
I MEAN, CAMERA LOVES HER.
SHE COULD DO MUCH BETTER
WITH REHEARSALS AND TIME.
>> SHE FELL APART AT THE END
WHEN SHE KISSED THE GUY.
(LAUGHS)
>> THE KISS. OOH!
>> SHE'S GOTTA LEARN TO KISS!
>> CARIDEE.
>> THE LIGHT ISN'T ON,
AND IF SHE THINKS SHE CAN
GET AWAY WITH A PERFORMANCE
AS POOR AS THAT...
>> IT WAS THE WORST.
>> MAYBE THE WORST EVER IN "TOP
MODEL" HISTORY.
I MEAN, IT WAS LUDICROUS.
>> SHE COMPLETELY WENT TO
PIECES.
I MEAN, IT SHOCKED ME, ACTUALLY.
>> CARI IS ONE OF THOSE GIRLS
THAT I WAS LIKE,
OH, SHE'S JUST GONNA BE
CONSISTENTLY DOING WELL.
AND THEN TO SEE THIS,
IT REALLY KIND OF SCARES ME.
>>LIKE, WHO IS SHE?
>> I KNOW.
>> DO YOU THINK SHE DID BAD
BECAUSE SHE WON THE CHALLENGE
THIS WEEK,
SO SHE'S LIKE,
"OKAY, I'M SO GREAT.
I DON'T HAVE TO TRY"?
>> I THINK SHE WAS RESTING ON
THAT,
BUT GUESS WHAT?
THIS IS WHEN IT GETS SERIOUS,
AND IF THIS IS
THE SERIOUS PERFORMANCE,
HEY, THE CURTAINS ARE DOWN.
>> WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
♪ ♪
>> SIX GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE FIVE PHOTOS IN
MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE FIVE YOUNG LADIES THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT I'M GOING TO
CALL...
MELROSE.
YOU KICKED BUTT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU REALLY, REALLY DID,
AND THAT LITTLE EXTRA SOMETHING
THAT YOU GAVE PAID OFF.
CONGRATULATIONS...
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M GOING TO
CALL...
EUGENA.
EUGENA, THESE JUDGES
ARE SAYING THAT BARCELONA HAS
DONE YOU WELL.
WE SAW A LIGHT IN YOU THAT WE'VE
NEVER SEEN.
EUGENA'S SOMEBODY TO LOOK OUT
FOR NOW.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M GOING TO
CALL...
AMANDA.
SO WE SAW YOUR COMMERCIAL,
AND WE WERE LIKE,
"SHE'S NOT SO DREADFUL."
>> (LAUGHS)
>> BUT YOU DON'T WANT TO BE NOT
SO DREADFUL.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> YOU WANNA BE AMAZING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M GOING TO
CALL...
MICHELLE.
YOU LOOKED ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL
IN THE COMMERCIAL,
BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
>> (CHUCKLES)
>> AND YOU HAVE SO MUCH SPUNK
AND SO MUCH FIRE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANKS.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
OH, I MEAN, GRACIAS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WILL JAEDA AND CARIDEE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL CALL ONLY ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO YOUR APARTMENT
HERE IN BARCELONA,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
CARIDEE, YOU'RE THE GIRL
THAT IS SO FULL OF LIFE,
THAT FROM WEEK TO WEEK
TAKES AMAZING PICTURES.
>> (MOUTHS WORDS)
>> THE JUDGES LOVE CARIDEE...
UP UNTIL TODAY,
BECAUSE A BIG PART OF THIS WIN
IS TO HAVE A COVERGIRL CONTRACT,
AND IT'S NOT JUST
POSING IN A PICTURE
FOR A COVERGIRL PRODUCT.
IT'S ABOUT BEING IN A
COMMERCIAL,
AND WHAT WE SAW TODAY IS A GIRL
THAT CAN'T DELIVER THAT.
AND, JAEDA, YOU'RE A GIRL
THAT HAS HAD PROBABLY NINE LIVES
IN THIS COMPETITION.
YOU'VE STOOD BEFORE ME
MORE THAN ONCE.
SOME JUDGES DOUBT
YOUR PASSION FOR THIS,
BUT THEN THERE'S OTHER JUDGES
BEHIND ME THAT SAY,
"BUT HER BONE STRUCTURE
AND HER FACE IS SO STRONG."
AND SOME GIRLS NEED
A LITTLE BIT MORE GROOMING,
A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME.
SO WHO GOES HOME--THE GIRL
THAT THE JUDGES DON'T THINK
CAN DELIVER A COMMERCIAL...
OR THE GIRL THAT NEEDS
A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME?
I THINK YOU CAN
DELIVER A COMMERCIAL, CARIDEE.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN SO HAPPY
TO SEE MYSELF.
(LAUGHS)
>> I THINK YOU CAN DO IT.
I THINK SOMETIMES WHEN
WE GET SO MUCH PRAISE,
WE'RE LIKE,
I'M FINE, I'M FUNNY, I'M GREAT.
NOW IT'S LIKE, CARIDEE'S NOT
PERFECT.
>> YEAH, I KNOW THAT.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, JAEDA.
GIVE ME A HUG.
>> THANK YOU.
I AM DISAPPOINTED
IN HOW EVERYTHING WENT DOWN.
IT WAS HORRIBLE,
AND IT REALLY WASN'T
A GREAT WAY TO, LIKE, LEAVE.
BUT I TRY TO MAKE IT POSITIVE.
LIKE, THEY OBVIOUSLY
SEE SOMETHING IN ME,
AND IT KIND OF MADE ME WANT TO
TRY HARDER IN THE COMPETITION.
BEING INSECURE WITH MY HAIR
AND ALL THAT,
IT--IT DEFINITELY TOOK ME
A LONGER TIME
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS TO, LIKE,
DEVELOP ALL THOSE, LIKE,
CHARACTERISTICS THAT YOU NEED
TO BE IN THIS COMPETITION,
BUT IT'S GONNA WORK OUT,
YOU KNOW?
THINGS ARE GONNA WORK OUT.
♪ ♪